Hôm Ké cho thấy giữ liệu của khoảng 1,5% trị báo dí động đã được đồng bộ lưới nệ thống viê nha đi
Tuy nhiên, vẫn còn hàng chục trị báo chứ thực hiện sắc nhận số địa thoại đang sử dụng là chính trụ
Chào quý định tại thông tin số không tảm về sắc thực sự báo dí động có giữ lực
Tương ngày 15 tháng tư người dung thị phải trụ đồng kìm chá và sắc nhận các số địa thoại được tên mình
Chên đứng dụng viê nha đi
Sau thời hạn ngâm lắm thằng sau những thui báo chứa sắc nhận giữ khoảng 1 chiều để thực hiện chuẩn hả thông tin
Thông quán biê này đi người dân có thể chắc cúto hàng bộ dưới thoại đang kì dưới tên mình
Sắc nhận số đang sử dụng và loại bỏ những số không còn dùng phó không phải là của mình
Cô bên thông quyền cáo người dân sớm thực hiện sắc nhận thông tin tuy báo nhằm bảo vệ quy lợi càng nhận
Đồng thời gó phần nhanh chẳng xin giác, hạn chế luật đồng chực tuyến và tăng cửa ngăn tỏng trên một chục số
Quý trình sát thật được thực hiện chực tuyến cho phép người dùng thao tăng mọi lúc mọi người mà không cần đến tư điểm sau dịch quyền nhằm mặt
Cô ký vị kể từ ngày 1,5 năm hành in không trong bài sau nhiều quy định mới tế bảo hiệm mít ấy sẽ chính thức có hiệu lực
Chúng đau đáng chú ý là việc tăng mức hưởng nối với một số trình hợp khám chữa bệnh ngoại chủ
Cào quy định mới người có thể bảo hiệm mít ấy khi khám ngoại chủ trai tuyến tại một số cơ sở khảm chữa bệnh
Cấp cơ bản và cấp chuyên sâu sẽ được quy bảo hiệm mít ấy thành phản nâng mấy tình chăm mức hưởng trong phạm vi quyền lợi được hưởng
Bệnh đau với các lần khám chữa bệnh có tổng chivy giữ mấy lắm phần trang mất lương cơ sở tương đương dưới ba trang bệnh mươi chiến nghiệm năm trong đông
Người bệnh khám đúng tuyến sẽ được quy bảo hiệm mít ấy chỉ trả 1 trong phần trang chivy thuộc phạm vi được hưởng
Không phải đông chiv trả như chưa đây
Các bối tế đây là những điểm mới quan trọng có phần giảm thánh nận chivy khám chữa bệnh Trung người dân
Đông thời mở giọng quy lợi đối với người tham gia bảo hiệm mít ấy
Các quay định mới dựa đất áp dụng kể từ ngày 1,5 bệnh năm nay nghe in không tra mình sấu theo lợi bảo hiệm mít ấy xưa đôi